ADAM MARTIN: All right.
So in Monday's
lecture, we talked
about how cells replicate, OK?
And today, I want to talk about
how now an entire organ would
essentially replicate.
In this case, it's
not going to divide,
but it's going to regenerate
or renew itself, OK?
And so this involves adult
stem cells and also apoptosis ,
which you've heard a little bit
about earlier in the course.
And to explain this to you, I'm
going to have basically a model
organ that we'll use.
And we'll use it for
a couple lectures.
And the model organ is going to
be the lining of the intestine,
OK?
So the lining of the intestine
is an epithelial tissue.
And I'll tell you a
little bit about epithelia
in just a minute.
But you have the
intestinal epithelium.
And this is the-- these
are the cells that
are the lining of
the intestine, OK?
And one of the reasons that
I've chosen this system
is because the lining
of your intestine
has pretty remarkable
regenerative capabilities, OK?
So your small intestine renews
about every four to five days,
OK?
So the vast majority of
your cells in the intestine
were basically derived in the
last four to five days, OK?
So humans aren't as
cool as some organisms,
like newts, in that you
can't cut off your arm
and have it grow back.
But at least we
have the intestine,
which undergoes a pretty
dramatic regeneration, OK?
And this is not--
the intestine is unique
in how rapid this is.
But you have other tissues that
also exhibit continual renewal,
like your skin and
your blood cells.
And even the cells
of your that line
your insides of your lungs,
they do exhibit renewal
capabilities, OK?
And so I'm going to use the
intestine as a model system.
It doesn't mean it doesn't
happen in other tissues.
But it just happens
that we can--
we really understand
the intestine system
maybe a little bit more
than many other systems.
So I'm going to use
it as an example.
So in thinking about the
lining of your intestine,
it's important, and it
has important functions.
One important function
of this lining
is it has to absorb
nutrients from food going
through your intestine, OK?
So it exhibits a nutrient
absorption function.
Now, the lining of your intimate
intestine, much like your skin,
is also a barrier between
the inside of your body
and the outside world, right?
Because basically, the
inside of your intestine
is contiguous with the
outside world, right?
If you open your
mouth, you can get down
to the inside of
your intestine, OK?
So it serves also an
important barrier function.
And one point I want to make
about this system right now
is that the intestinal
epithelium, like many
of your other organs, are
composed of multiple cell
types, OK?
So it also has
multiple cell types.
OK.
So let's now consider the
lining of the intestine.
And the way the intestine
morphologically looks
is that there are a
series of invaginations.
So this is a cross-section
view through the intestine.
So you have to imagine that
this is a cross-section view,
but that this is a plane.
And it's a plane with a lot
of invaginations in the plane,
but also protrusions
out of the plane.
And so you have to remember--
you have to think of
this as a surface.
And then it's wrapped
up into a tube, OK?
So this is just a very
simple cross-section image
of the intestine, OK?
And the lining of the
intestine is a sheet of cells.
So this lining is composed
of many, many cells.
They're columnar in morphology.
So what I've drawn here
is just a small section
of the intestine.
This would be the
lumen, out here.
This is where the
food is, or the food
going through your
intestine would be.
And then below here, this
is interstitial fluid inside
of your body basically,
interstitial, OK?
So the food's up here.
The rest of your
body is down here.
And you can see
that there are there
there's a structure to it.
It's not just a flat
surface that's wrapped up,
but there are invaginations.
And the invaginations are known
as intestinal crypts, right?
Much like you would--
if you bury something, like a
body, it would go below ground.
So the crypt is below
the surface of the lumen.
And this these projections,
out here, are known as villi.
So they're the villi
of your gut, OK?
Now, if we consider--
and this lining is made
up of multiple cell
types, which I've
outlined up here
and which are in your handout.
So you don't have
to write these down.
But this is just
making the point
that there are various
differentiated cell types.
There are enterocytes, which
are the absorptive cells.
These are the cells that
are taking in nutrients
and transporting
them into your body.
There are enteroendocrine
cells that
play an important signaling
function in the gut to regulate
the biology of the gut system.
There are a goblet cells,
which secrete mucus
into the intestine system, which
protects these epithelial cells
from digestive enzymes that
are present in the lumen.
And there is this last
cell type, the paneth cell,
which functions as an important
role in regulating stem cells,
as I'll outline
in just a minute.
So these are all the
differentiated cell types.
But there's a type
of cell that's
an undifferentiated cell type.
And that's the
intestinal stem cell,
which will be the hero
of today's lecture.
All right.
Now, if we consider just
a small group of cells,
what these cells look
like is this, OK?
So these are what are
known as epithelial cells.
And epithelial cells
have certain properties.
The first is you see that this
end of the epithelial cell
looks different
from this end, OK?
And this is called an
apical-basal polarity.
So much like neurons
have a polarity where
the on one side of the
neuron there are dendrites
and on the other side of
the neuron there's an axon,
these cells have another
type of polarity, which is
called apical-basal polarity.
So the side facing
the lumen is apical.
So the lumen would be up here.
And the basal side
would be down here, OK?
So this is basically oriented
along this axis of the tissue,
OK?
where apical is on this side,
basal is on this side, OK?
And these projections from
the individual cell, these
are called microvilli.
And essentially,
these plasma membrane
corrugations increase
the surface area
through which nutrients can be
absorbed into these cells, OK?
Now, one other defining
feature of these cells
is they have proteins that
protrude from the plasma
membrane.
And these are adhesion proteins
that couple the cells together.
And actually, the cells
are stuck together
much tighter than I'm
drawing here, such
that the cells form a
barrier so that things
can pass unregulated from
the lumen into the body, OK?
But these proteins,
which I'm drawing
sticking out of the
membranes of the cells,
are adhesion proteins.
And these adhesion
proteins simply
link the cells together
such that they form
a sheet of cells or tissue.
So they link cells together, OK?
So these are two of the key
properties of epithelia.
They have an
apical-basal polarity.
And they also exhibit
cell-to-cell adhesion,
such as the cells reach out
and connect to each other.
And they basically are glued
together, or Velcroed together
such that they don't
easily come apart.
OK.
Now, in considering this
system, what I'm going to tell
you is that there is
renewal of this lining.
And the renewal starts at
the base of the crypts, OK?
So there's going to be renewal.
And this cell renewal is at
the base of the crypts, right?
There are many of
these crypts, right?
You have you have
like the surface,
but there are many,
many invaginations
that are present in your gut.
And the renewal is happening at
the base of these crypts, OK?
And that's because at
the base of these crypts
are where a type of cell, known
as intestinal stem cells, lie,
OK?
So it's at the base
of these crypts
where there are what are known
as intestinal stem cells.
And I'm going to abbreviate
these ISCs for this,
so I don't have to write
out intestinal stem cell
whenever I tell
you about them, OK?
Now, that's where
renewal occurs.
And if you just had more
and more cells getting
put in the system without
any removal of cells,
then the organ would get
bigger and bigger, right?
And so our intestine
more or less
staying the same size at
this point in our life.
And so in addition to renewal,
there's also cell death.
And what happens when
cell death occurs
is that cells are shed
from the intestinal lining
into the lumen.
So cells are shed
And then they just go with
the rest of the crap that's
in your intestinal lumen.
And it's eventually
removed from the body, OK?
So some cells are leaving the
tissue and going into the lumen
after they've existed for a
few days in the intestine, OK?
So to have an organ
then the constant size
renewal has to essentially be
more or less equal to death,
OK?
And so you can think of this
as a type of homeostatic state
for this tissue where, if
renewal equals death, you have
what is known as tissue
homeostasis, where
the number of cells in
the system as a whole
is basically remaining the same,
even though there's constantly
new cells going
into this system.
But then the cells are also--
the older cells are being
removed from the system.
So what's really
key in this process
are these intestinal stem cells.
So I'm first going to
tell you about stem cells.
And these are what I would
define as adult stem cells, OK?
So they're stem cells
that are associated
with a particular organ, OK?
And I want to
differentiate this right
now between these
types of stem cells
and another type of
stem cell that we're
going to talk about later
in the course, which
is an embryonic stem cell.
So adult stem cells--
these stem cells, like
intestinal stem cells,
are associated with
a specific organ.
And they only give
rise to cell types that
are present in that organ, OK?
So they're not-- they can't give
rise to any type of cell type.
Your adult stem cells are really
specific-- organ-specific,
we'll say.
In contrast, embryonic
stem cells are--
these stem cells have
more possibilities.
They can give rise to
pretty much any cell
type in an entire organism, OK?
So you can think of
these adult stem cells
as being more restricted
in their fates
than the embryonic stem cells.
And so what adult
stem cells are called
is they're called multipotent,
because they can give rise
to multiple
different cell types,
but not all of the
cell types that are
present in an organism, right?
An intestinal stem cell
will not be giving rise
to a blood cell or other cell
types in other organs, right?
It's restricted to
just giving rise
to cells that are
present in that organ.
In contrast,
embryonic stem cells
are what are known as
totipotent, or sometimes
pluripotent, where
this type of cell
really is capable of making
any type of cell that
is present in an
adult organism, OK?
So that's less restricted
than the adult stem cells.
And we're going to come back
to these embryonic stem cells
towards the end of the course.
But for understanding
cancer and also
tissue homeostasis
in the intestine,
we're really needing to focus
on the adult stem cells.
OK.
So these adult stem cells
have two key properties.
The first is what I just said.
They're multipotent.
And what multipotent
means is that they
can give rise to multiple
different cell types.
So this stem cell gives
rise to multiple cell types.
And this is associated usually
with a single organ system.
OK.
So in the case of the
intestinal stem cell,
the intestinal stem
cell is multipotent.
And it can give rise to
many different terminally
differentiated cells.
And you can see here I've just
written in example cell types
that the intestinal
cell could generate.
It can generate any of the
four different types of cells
that I introduced to you at
the beginning of the lecture.
The other key aspect
of this system
is that, in addition
to generating
all of these
different cell types,
the stem cell can
also renew itself, OK?
So the other key property
is this self-renewal.
So the intestinal stem
cell also gives rise
to another intestinal stem cell.
So it basically
duplicates itself such
that you still have a
stem cell in the organ.
And then one of
the daughter cells
is self-renewed and
remains a stem cell.
The other daughter cell
can go on to divide
further and give rise to these
differentiated cell types, OK?
All right.
So one question
you might be asking
yourself is, how is it that--
what regulates
whether or not a cell
will go on to
differentiate or whether it
will stay a stem cell?
And the answer to
this question involves
communication between
this stem cell
and other cells in the system.
And it involves a
special type of cell
called a stem cell niche cell.
And so I'm going to tell
you about a model, which
is the stem cell niche model.
And what the stem
cell niche model is,
is that basically there is
a niche or compartment which
promotes the self-renewal of
cells in that compartment that
makes them stem cells.
So the stem cell niche you can
think of as a compartment where
signals, similar to the types of
signals that we've been talking
about over the past
four or five lectures,
regulate the behavior of the
cell to ensure self-renewal
and to suppress differentiation,
so a compartment
where signals promote
stem cell renewal.
I want to ask you one question
before I move on, which
is, how would you define--
how would you
determine that there
is a special type of cell
that gives rise to all
of the cells in an organ?
If you were tasked with
finding this and determining
whether this was true or
not, how might you do it?
Does anyone have an idea of
what experiment they would do,
or what criteria they would
have to determine whether or not
this is a case?
Let's say I gave
you a cell, right?
In a dish.
And I asked you to
tell me whether or not
you would think this
is a stem cell or not.
Yes, miles?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM MARTIN: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: One cell is
produced by the same cell,
assuming that it's
not a stem cell
but if the cell [INAUDIBLE]
it's a stem cell.
ADAM MARTIN: Mm-hmm.
So Miles suggested he would like
to take the cell that I just
gifted him, and let it grow up,
and determine whether it gives
rise to multiple cell types.
And Miles said that,
if it just gave rise
to a single cell type,
that would suggest
that it's not a stem cell.
But if it gave rise to
multiple cell types,
then it could be
a stem cell, OK?
And it's this type
of experiment that--
this type of experiment
has been done,
where you can take an
intestine from mice,
and even you can take
tissue from humans,
and you can associate
the cells from each other
so that you're left with
single cells that are separate.
And you can then use some
type of flow cytometry
to separate cells.
And you might be
interested in a cell that
maybe expresses some marker
that you're interested in.
And you can separate those
cells and isolate them.
And then you can take
an individual cell
and grow it in a dish, OK?
And this has been done
for intestinal stem cells.
And if you take an
intestinal stem cell
and you grow it in a
dish, it can grow up
and form a bulk of tissue.
But what's really
remarkable about the result
of this experiment is
that, from a stem cell,
you get this massive tissue.
But it self--organizes into
a structure that very much
resembles a normal gut, meaning
that there are crypts where
the stem cells are localized.
And then if you look
at the different cell
types in this, what's
known as an organoid,
you see all of the different
cell types that are normally
present in the gut, OK?
And so this is an example
of a type of experiment
that's done to
show whether or not
a certain cell has the
capability of functioning
like a stem cell, OK?
So if you start
with a stem cell,
you can regenerate the entire
organ system essentially.
You might also be familiar
with bone marrow transplants.
And so if you kill all the
hematopoietic stem cells
in, let's say, a
mouse, then you can
transplant in a single
hematopoietic stem cell
into that system.
And it will regenerate all the
blood cells in that system, OK?
So those are just a few examples
of how one might functionally
define a stem cell in
an experimental setting.
All right.
So now, I want to tell you
about the types of signals
and how these signals are
promoting stem cell renewal,
OK?
So in this case, the
niche, stem cell niche
is going to be right here.
And the types of
signals involved--
I'll just draw some cells here.
One of the types of
cells that's part
of the niche in the
intestine is the cell type
that I introduced you
as the paneth cell.
And these paneth cells localized
to the base of the crypts
together with the
intestinal stem cells.
And what paneth cells
do is they send a signal
to neighboring cells.
And this signal is a Wnt
signal, which I'll tell you
about in just a minute.
And so this is the
intestinal stem cell here.
And the paneth cell is signaling
to that intestinal stem cell
through a secreted
ligand known as Wnt.
So Wnt is a secreted ligand.
And this signal is what's known
as a juxtacrine signal, which
just means that the cells
have to be adjacent,
or juxtaposed, to each other
in order for the sending cell
to signal to its neighbor, OK?
So it's not
signaling long range,
but it's signaling to
a neighboring cell, OK?
So now, if we think about
this intestinal stem cell,
one thing intestinal stem
cells do as they divide, right?
So this intestinal
stem cell could divide.
Here is a cell in mitosis.
It rounds up and divides.
Here, you still have
your paneth cell.
And then when this
cell divides, then it's
going to be two cells, OK?
So now, paneth
cell, another cell.
Here the two daughter cells.
Here's the paneth cell.
The paneth cell is still
secreting this Wnt signal.
So you have Wnt
getting secreted.
And it's going to
signal to its neighbor.
But this cell is starting
to get farther and farther
away from that signal, right?
So you can imagine this
is happening right here
in the tissue,
where this cell is
at the boundary
of the niche, OK?
So this cell that gets
pushed out of the niche
is going to start to
differentiate, OK?
Because it's no longer
seeing the signal, OK?
So it's the lack
of the Wnt signal
which tells cells
basically that they
should start differentiating
into the various cell
types of the gut.
But the cells that are stuck
at the base of the crypt,
down with the paneth cells, are
still getting the Wnt signal.
And so they remain an
intestinal stem cell, OK?
So here is just a diagram
showing you part of that.
So the niche is down here,
where you have the stem cells.
The paneth cells would be
some of these blue cells
at the base.
But there are also other cells
below the epithelial lining
known as stromal cells that
are also secreting Wnt.
And so this
compartment down here
has high Wnt ligan activity.
And that tells cells that
remain here to stay stem cells.
But the cells that
are getting pushed up
and moving up towards
the lumen, they no longer
receive this signal.
And so they are going to
start to differentiate, OK?
So you can think of this
system as almost a conveyor
belt. There's a conveyor
belt-like movement of cells
from the base of the crypt up
towards the tip of the villis,
OK?
And when the cells move
away from the niche cells,
then they no longer have
the self-renewal signal.
And therefore, they go
on to differentiate.
OK.
We'll go back for now.
All right.
Now, I want to tell you a little
bit about this signal, Wnt,
because it's something that's
come up before in the lecture,
even though you
might not know it.
So Wnt is a ligand.
So it functions much
like a growth factor.
This is a protein that is
secreted from the cell,
and then binds to
receptors on other cells,
and induces signaling
events in those cells, OK?
And Wnt stands for--
the W stands for wingless, OK?
So you remember from
earlier in the semester,
wingless was
identified as a mutant
that disrupts the formation
of wings in the fly, OK?
So one of the places where
these genes were discovered
is in the fly.
The nt of Wnt comes
from int 1, which
stands for the integration
of mouse mammary virus 1.
Sorry, that's a little
bit more of a mouthful.
The integration of mouse--
actually, sorry, mouse
mammary tumor virus 1.
I forgot the tumor part of it.
OK.
So the W in Wnt
is from wingless.
The nt in Wnt is from int 1, OK?
And so as you can see, there
are two different systems
where this type of
gene was discovered.
They are very disparate
from each other.
One was in a developmental
mutant, in the fruit fly.
The other was in a
mouse system, where
the integration of the
virus caused over-expression
of Wnt, which caused it
as tumor genesis, OK?
So these disparate systems
led to the identification
of this Wnt molecule.
And this is a defining
member of a signaling pathway
that regulates
stem cell renewal.
And I just want to briefly
go through the logic
of the signaling
pathway, because I want
you to get a sense that not
all signaling pathways are
like Ras-MAP kinase,
but there can be
different regulatory logic, OK?
So what's the regulatory
logic of this pathway?
So the regulatory logic
is shown in this cartoon.
And I'm going to
start with a cell that
does not see Wnt ligand.
So that would be the
case on the left here.
So if there's no Wnt ligand--
I want you to focus on
what's going on here--
there's a complex that's present
in the cytoplasm of the cell.
And what it's doing
is it's destroying
this beta-catenin protein, OK?
So what beta-catenin is--
among other things, it's a
transcriptional coactivator.
So it's basically a
transcription factor.
So it works with another protein
to regulate the expression
of certain genes, OK?
And in the absence of Wnt,
this beta-catenin transcription
factor is destroyed and is not
able to get into the nucleus,
OK?
So if there's no Wnt, then
beta-catenin is destroyed.
And it's destroyed
using a system
that I introduced in
Monday's lecture, which
is regulated proteolysis
by polyubiquitination, OK?
So the first real--
so you have
regulated proteolysis
by polyubiquitination.
So the way this
works, as seen here,
is that beta-catenin is
bound by this complex.
And there's a kinase that
phosphorylates beta-catenin.
And then the
phosphorylated beta-catenin
recruits this E3
ubiquitin ligase, which
polyubiquitinates it, OK?
So that leads to the
destruction of beta-catenin
in the absence of a Wnt signal.
But when Wnt ligand
is around, this
leads to the disassembly of
this complex, which is known
as the destruction complex.
And that leads to
beta-catenin accumulating.
And once it accumulates,
it goes into the nucleus
and starts changing
gene expression, OK?
So in the presence of Wnt,
beta-catenin is nuclear.
And that's where it needs to
be, if it's going to regulate
gene expression, OK?
So what you see is the
logic of this pathway
is you have a double
negative, where
you have a complex, which
is known as the destruction
complex.
And it includes this
gene, APC, which we're
going to talk about on Friday.
This destruction complex
is inhibiting beta-catenin
by destroying it.
And the way that Wnt induces
beta-catenin activation
is by inhibiting the inhibitor.
So Wnt inhibits the
destruction complex,
which then stabilizes
beta-catenin and allows
it to go to the nucleus, OK?
So the other piece
of the logic here
is you have inhibition
of an inhibitor
to activate beta-catenin.
Any questions on the pathway?
OK.
So now that we have our
intestinal stem cells
and we have a way, by increasing
Wnt in this compartment,
to maintain the intestinal stem
cells through self-renewal, now
we have to talk about
the compensatory
mechanism of death,
which allows this tissue
to maintain homeostasis.
OK.
So death-- in this case,
death is going to be useful.
And the process of death
is called apoptosis.
And apoptosis is
Greek for falling off.
And that's essentially
what these cells
are doing, because
the cells, as they
move from the base of the
crypt up towards the lumen--
eventually, they're
going to fall off
into the lumen of the intestine.
So again, I'll draw.
Here's a villus.
This is now a villus.
And so what happens is,
at the tip of the villus,
cells are going to be shed from
the lining of the epithelium
into the lumen.
The lumen is up here.
This is the villus.
And the cells are going
to shed off into the lumen
and be removed from
the organ system, OK?
So cells are shed into
the lumen here, OK?
And this is going to
balance the renewal
at the base of the crypts
such that there's homeostasis.
So I just-- the movie
I was showing you
at the beginning of class
was a movie showing you
what happens to a cell
undergoing apoptosis.
So in this case, the cell
is binucleate and unhappy.
And then you're going to see
that it basically explodes, OK?
So that's a cell
undergoing apoptosis.
But you see that there is a
clear change in cell morphology
and physiology
associated with this.
And I just want to point out
that this is also something
that we talked about
earlier in the course.
And we talked about experiments,
a genetic screen that
led to the identification
of the pathway that
regulates apoptosis.
And that was done
by Robert Horvitz.
Much of it was done by Robert
Horvitz in his lab here at MIT.
And for that work, Robert
Horvitz, in addition to
his colleagues, won
the 2002 Nobel Prize.
So you'll recall
this is something
we talked about in the
context of a genetic screen.
But this is something that's--
this is what it's doing
in your intestine system.
It's balancing renewal so
that you have homeostasis.
So during apoptosis, a cell goes
through a series of changes.
First-- or what
happens eventually
is the nucleus becomes
fragmented and chromosomal DNA
even gets fragmented.
It gets chopped up.
And also, the
plasma membrane also
starts to bleb and fragment
such that it breaks up
into what are known as
these apoptotic bodies, OK?
And so you can think of
these apoptotic bodies
as bite-sized pieces of
cell that neighboring
phagocytic cells can eat up and
remove them from the body, OK?
So in this case, the cells
are being shed into the lumen.
So they don't need
to get eaten up,
because they're just going to
go out of the digestive tract.
So there are-- cells
have numerous ways
to activate this
apoptosis process.
I'm going to tell you
about two types of signals
that regulate whether or not
a cell undergoes apoptosis.
The first is that there can be
a signal that basically tells
the cell to kill itself, OK?
So you can think of
this as a kill signal.
And one type of way to
activate this signal
is if the DNA is
irreparably damaged.
So if there is a high
level of DNA damage,
this induces a signaling
process in the cell.
And one of the results
of that signal--
in addition to regulating
the cell cycle,
if the DNA damage
is great enough,
it will induce an
apoptotic signal.
And it will activate the pathway
that the Horvitz lab elucidated
in the worm, OK?
So there's a signal.
And that leads to
apoptosis and death.
Another type of signal that's
critically important for tissue
homeostasis and determining
whether or not cells live
or die is a survival signal.
So there are cell
survival signals.
And many of the growth factors,
such as EGF which you've heard
about--
in addition to
inducing proliferation,
these growth factors also
tell the cell not to die, OK?
So these could be
growth factors.
And what these cell
survival signals do
is they repress apoptosis.
And so you can think
of it where you have
a cell constantly needs
to be communicated to.
And it needs to
be told don't die,
don't die, don't die, don't die.
And then if you
remove that signal,
it won't be getting that
information anymore.
And it can undergo
apoptosis, OK?
So if we were to
remove this signal,
you remove the
brakes on apoptosis.
And the cell will
undergo cell death, OK?
So this ensures that you
don't have a cell just kind
of like going on and
doing its own thing,
because cells, in
order to live, often
need to have some sort of
signal from another cell that
tells them to live.
And so there's some
coordination between cells such
that you don't have
cells rampantly
dividing out of control.
Now, the reason we're
doing this right
before we talk about
cancer on Friday
is because everything
that I'm telling you
is really essential to
understand how a tumor is
formed in an organ system, OK?
And I want to end the
lecture by just planting
a seed of an idea in your
heads before we move on
to talk about cancer on Friday.
And I want you to think
about the organization
of this system, where you have
stem cells undergoing renewal.
And then the stem cells
are just a small fraction
of the cells in the system.
And they're dividing slowly, OK?
So let's think about
the stem cells.
The DNA on the stem cells,
these are dividing slowly.
And because they're
dividing slowly,
they're not going
to-- their DNA is not
going to accumulate
as many mutations.
So there is going to
be fewer mutations.
But these are the
cells, and this
is the genomic DNA that is going
to stay with the organ, OK?
So the stem cells are like
the crown jewels of the organ.
This is the material the
organ wants to protect,
because it's what's
going to be lasting
in the organ the entire
lifetime of the organism, OK?
So you get slow division
here and self-renewal.
And this cell will
stay with the organ.
But then where most of the
mitosis and cell division
happens and
replication happens, it
leads to an expansion of
cells that all differentiate.
And because the cells
all differentiate,
they will all eventually die and
get removed from the organ, OK?
And this is termed
transient amplification.
So when there's transient
amplification of one
of the daughters
of this stem cell,
this is where there's
rapid division.
And where there is rapid
replication and division,
this is where you can
get the most mutations.
But from the
standpoint of cancer,
that doesn't really
matter, right?
Because in order
to have a tumor,
the cells have to
stay in the body.
And so all of these
cells are going
to undergo programmed
cell death,
and then be shed into the
lumen of the intestine
and removed from the
organism entirely, OK?
And so this is actually
one important way
that our organs and our bodies
prevent tumors from happening,
because the cell type that is
going to remain in our body
is the one that's protected
from accumulating mutations, OK?
And we'll come back
to this on Friday.
And so I will see you on Friday.
And we'll talk about
cancer on Friday.